David Harris, from Colorado Springs, is asking about the courses we have
listed on the bottom of our home page.
So we do have plans to offer more courses.
I gather you've noticed the ones listed
on the bottom of the home page are fairly vague.
They don't say, specifically, what the courses are or when they're going to start.
We will be announcing some courses soon; we don't want to announce
specifics about courses until we're really sure they're in place.
But there will be new courses starting in April, including several courses
that you'll be able to take, building just on this CS101course,
and I think they're going to be really exciting--but I can't announce them just yet.
But you will be hearing more about those very soon. >>Soon.